(percussion music)
- I have done print
modeling, underwear, fitness.
- Done a lot of runway, print,
mostly for new designers
in the LA area.
- I have never had braces.
- I had braces for three years,
from the end of eighth grade
up until about junior year of high school.
My teeth were atrocious.
I could fit a straw
between my two front teeth.
I love the end result.
I wish it didn't have to last three years.
- I think braces is just kind
of like a whatever thing,
and people make it out to be a big deal,
and so I'm like, oh,
well, I'll try it out.
- I don't think it's
going to phase me at all.
- I'm excited about it.
(percussion music)
- That looks about right.
- Oh, my God. (laughs)
I have so much saliva in my mouth.
Look at them, they're just like there.
I can't really smile.
- I got the reaction from
friends that I thought I would
where they would just crack
jokes and ask me if I was
going through puberty.
- (Courtney) Look at these braces.
- Oh, my God.
Are they actually, those are fake teeth.
- (Courtney) They look ridiculous.
- They look beautiful.
- If you want straight teeth, you gotta,
you gotta suffer for a little bit.
It's all you can do.
- No one has really been crazy.
I've been smiling,
because I really can't close my mouth.
- There was a time where
I did run my tongue across
my teeth with the braces on,
and it did give me some
flashbacks to cutting my tongue,
or my lip, or actually having braces
which was a pain.
- Oh, my God.
I just woke up.
They do hurt.
So annoying.
- Based on facial expressions,
I don't think people
really reacted or cared.
- I went everywhere and nobody really like
looked at me differently.
They didn't care that I had them.
They weren't like, why do you have braces?
Nobody really talked about it.
- Be confident in your own skin
and like I said, braces aren't forever.
You'll get them off and the
end result is definitely
worth it.
(pop music)